Привет. В прошлый раз мы вывели продукт в сети, получили публичную ссылку. Он рабочий,
открывается с любого устройства, можно давать людям на тесты. И тут возникает главный вопрос
дизайнера: а доходят ли по нему люди до цели? И если нет, то где они спотыкаются? Сегодня соберём
ответ на это по данным на живых людях. Сразу мысль, на которую ложится весь урок. Аналитика — это часть
кода. В прототип встраивается небольшой трекер, ты пушишь обновления, хостинг пересобирает живую
версию, и она начинает считать поведение пользователей. Дашборд потом читает эти
данные с живой версии. Поэтому метрики мы снимаем только после диплоя, без живой ссылки реального
теста не провести, тестировать просто не на чем. Ну а сам дашборд, который будет метрики снимать,
я уже для тебя сделал, останется его только интегрировать. Я думаю, очевидно, что в Figma полноценные
метрики снять нельзя, там нарисованные переходы по клику, один ровный сценарий. У нас на руках рабочий
продукт, и его можно проверять как продукт. Куда люди жмут, где они застревают, насколько
они проходят по воронкам, и подтверждаются ли те или иные гипотезы. Итак, как я ранее сказал,
сам дашборд тебе собирать не надо. Я уже собрал его за тебя. Ты просто скачаешь архив и установишь
свой проект. Но на живых продуктах уже и так есть приложения, с которыми проводят тестирование.
Поэтому давай отдельно отмечу, чем вообще отличается этот дашборд кастомный, который я собрал для тебя,
и почему это круче, чем прикручивать уже готовые инструменты. Типа амплитуд. Три вещи делает
его полезным именно дизайнеру. Первое – это сигналы трения он считает из чистых событий,
из маршрута и кликов, без записи экрана и без личных данных. Это приватнее, легче и не требует
писать видеосессий. Второе, и это для нас главное – он замыкает цикл. Большие инструменты показывают
проблему. И на этом все. Чинить, проверять – ты идешь в другое место. Здесь находка превращается в задачу
для агента. Агент вносит эту правку, и ты передеплоишь, и сразу видишь, помогло или нет.
Третье, он максимально честен за счет того, что он прикручен к твоей среде, работает в этом же
самом контексте, ориентируется на конкретные гипотезы. Туда они добавляются автоматически,
как и сценарии, которые новые у тебя появляются в продукте. Так что это унифицированный под тебя
инструмент, который тебе не нужно дорабатывать. Он дорабатывается сам твоим агентом.
Да, в чем-то это незамена большой продуктовой аналитики на миллионах пользователей. Это
инструмент дизайнера под быстрый юзер-тест прототипа. Мало людей, короткий цикл, правки
руками агента. Теперь о том, как он подключается. У нас есть директива и есть архив, папочка,
которую ты просто закинешь в папку своей среды. Распаковываешь архив в проект, запускаешь эту
директиву, и она сама как бы присасывает дашборд к твоему продукту. Ставит трекер в прототип,
поднимает сбор на сервере и подтягивает гипотезы с твоим проектом. Один момент важно понять,
иначе будет неясно, почему так. Сбор данных и хранение - это бэкэнд. Нужна программа на сервере,
которая принимает события и складывает их к себе. Ей нужен всегда включенный сервер с диском - тот самый,
что ты арендовал под VPN. На версель ее положить нельзя. Версель раздает статику и не держит
постоянный файл, в котором могли бы копиться эти данные. Поэтому правило простое: прототип может
жить где угодно, а данные всегда на твоем сервере. Тяжелый бэкэнд мы при этом не строим,
легкий сборщик уже в комплекте, его поднимает директива. Отсюда два пути, и директива спрашивает,
какой твой. Если прототип у тебя на своем сервере, все идет по HTTP, мы бегло затрагивали что это такое,
все у тебя на одной машине, ничего особенного подключать не нужно, директива сделает все моментально.
Если прототип на версель, есть нюанс - страница там открывается по HTTPS, а браузер со страницы HTTPS не пускает
запросы на HTTP сервер, блокирует их. Это просто разные уровни защиты. Я в предыдущем уроке освещал, что для того,
чтобы HTTPS получить, нужно получать домен, затем получать сертификат. Прежде чем ты получишь домен и сможешь его
привязать, тоже нужно подождать, ввести все записи. Короче, это долго неудобно, но сегодня мы,
кстати, для этого посмотрим небольшой обход. Он называется Ngrok, он через туннелирование дает этот
самый протокол твоему серверу, что позволяет обмениваться данными с верселем. В целом всю базу я
рассказал, давай теперь посмотрим, как это работает в S-коде. Итак, смотри, прежде всего у тебя появляется
здесь новая папка, она называется Dashboard. Мы ложим ее в корень среды и оставляем здесь. Сразу одно замечание,
не пытайся сюда перетянуть целую папку, у тебя немного собьется среда, нам это не нужно,
мы открываем именно файловое хранилище и туда эту папку закидываем. У тебя это будет в формате
архива, нужно будет распаковать и папку закинуть в свою среду с проектом. Также появится новая
директива, которая называется Dashboard. Запускаем ее в выполнение и он уже сам исходя из того,
что у тебя проект на версии либо на своем сервере, следует по шагам. Если у тебя на своем сервере, тебе там ничего
делать не нужно будет. Если у тебя проект на версии, он запросит у тебя три важных момента.
момента. Тебе нужно будет перейти на сайт ngrok и здесь скопировать для него два ключевых
параметра. Ну, во-первых, на самом этом сервисе можно зарегистрироваться, как бы с этим проблем
особо нет, все как везде. Но обрати внимание, что если у тебя GitHub привязан к российской почте,
mail.ru, например, именно регистрацию через GitHub не позволит сделать. Можешь это сделать через Gmail,
любой и как бы разницы особо не будет. Итак, что нам здесь нужно. Во-первых, слева в меню
найти your.toy.auf.token. Переходим сюда и просто копируем этот самый токен.
Отправляем агенту. Также здесь же для этого сервиса идем чуть ниже, выбираем
домены, открываем его и также копируем этот домен. Вставляем в строку с агентом. Все эти данные
он запросит и укажет, где тебе их взять. Просто визуально тебе показываю, чтобы тебе было удобнее.
И сами данные сервера те самые, которые ты вводил, когда настраивал себе VPN. Это его IP, это всегда root и пароль к этому root, к этой учетке.
Все это закидываем в агента и он поднимает наш дашбор. Сразу скажу, что возможно немного отличаться проект.
Не ко всем там кнопкам, частям прототипа он подвяжется. Хотя на самом деле должен, но всякое бывает.
Здесь возможен такой притирочный раунд, когда тебе нужно посмотреть, убедиться, что агент все правильно собрал.
Итак, после того, как он обновит версию, здесь он будет выдавать тебе сообщение о том, что он ожидает, пока там все обновится на этом версии.
Этого можно долго ждать, не всегда он действительно ждет, иногда просто делает вид, что ждет и что-то проверяет.
Просто заходишь на версии или смотришь, когда была последняя дата обновления твоего проекта.
Ну, там у тебя должно быть минуту назад, 50 секунд назад и так далее.
Здесь, если все прошло хорошо, не должно быть никаких уведомлений.
Если же здесь есть уведомления, просто скринишь их и отправляешь в чат с агентом.
Если здесь у нас статус ready, ты видишь, что только что обновился, был деплой.
Просто возвращаешься в агенты и пишешь, все, все задеплоилось, все окей.
После чего он выдаст тебе ссылку на твой дашборд, куда уже будут выходить все данные.
Итак, вот мой прототип, на него мы уже смотрели, давай посмотрим на тот самый дашборд, о котором я говорю.
Выглядит этот дашборд так.
Первая страница у нас обзорная, здесь расписаны раунды, сколько у нас было респондентов, сколько у нас уже есть сценарий, какие у нас гипотезы подтвердились, не подтвердились.
Здесь во все это можно углубиться.
Ну, можно пойти дальше и посмотреть на них уже отдельно.
Итак, например, гипотезы.
Все гипотезы ты прорабатываешь с агентом, создаешь новые и просто добавляешь их в дашборд, чтобы они собирали метрики, которые подтвердят, либо опровергнут их.
Вот, например, у нас есть гипотеза в задаче пополнения, первый клик уходит мимо, пополнить баланс, путь к пополнению не очевиден и так далее.
Описана целевая метрика, видим граф и смотрим, помещаемся мы сюда или нет.
Если что-то не так, то в чем причина.
Например, разобрать респонденты сессии, здесь у нас выводятся конкретные сессии.
Переходим в сессию, смотрим, что человек делал, сколько времени у него это занимало, как характеризуется это его действие.
Вот, например, там рейдж клик, это когда он много раз долбит в одном и том же месте и ничего не происходит.
Разворот, это когда он прошел вперед, снова назад вернулся.
Ну, здесь я думаю, что и так понятно все.
Таким образом, мы можем оценивать поведение пользователя и по показателю трения смотреть, насколько требует внимания этот флоу,
насколько там возникали проблемы у пользователя, насколько следует обратить внимание на то или иное прохождение.
Также гипотезы можно фильтровать, те, что подтвердились, не подтвердились, находятся на проверке и так далее.
Здесь у меня было, по-моему, три, да, только три респондента.
Это слишком мало, чтобы делать выводы по гипотезе, поэтому мне тут все еще на этапе нужен еще тест.
Вот, например, у меня с фейковыми данными, да, здесь отображается, не подтвердилась, либо подтвердилась гипотеза.
Точно так же сессии можем посмотреть.
Если у нас будет по какой-нибудь гипотезе, например, одинаковое количество положительных и отрицательных результатов,
то также будет выводиться, что нужен еще тест.
Дальше, сценарий — это те же самые юзерфлоу, то есть последовательность экранов, переходов.
А сценарий точно так же ты вместе с агентом создаешь, закидываешь и собираешь с них метрики.
Вот, например, здесь у меня два сценария — создать сервер, пополнить баланс.
Каждый из них запускается либо по метке, либо просто по входу.
Просто по входу — это любой заход на сервис записывается в этот сценарий.
Если у нас привязка по метке, то только перейдя по этой ссылке, пользователь запускает именно этот сценарий.
Это важно для того, чтобы сегментировать те или иные юзер-тесты.
То есть мы, например, тестируем сценарий пополнения баланса.
Для него он здесь нам создает отдельную ссылочку.
Мы закидываем ее респонденту.
Он проходит flow, и мы собираем уже по этому сценарию метрики.
Ну и здесь сводка.
Сколько доходит до цели?
Какая у нас вообще воронка сценария?
Ну, здесь не так интересно, потому что мало экранов и везде 100.
Вот, например, здесь с моковыми данными доходят до цели 4 из 8.
Время до цели, потерянность.
Воронка на каком этапе конкретно, на каком экране у нас отваливаются?
Здесь вот видно, что наибольший отвал на этапе создания сервера.
Значит, что-то не так, стоит обратить внимание.
Дальше у нас здоровье экранов.
Можно посмотреть, как много на каждом из экранов возникает трения,
как долго на нем в среднем проводят время.
И первый клик, то есть правильно ли они с первого действия идут по сценарию.
Это важно для того, чтобы оценить, прозрачно ли целевое действие.
Следующая вкладка у нас сессии.
Мы их также можем по конкретным сценариям фильтровать.
Фильтровать по устройствам он это собирает.
И по ключевым проблемам.
Человек заблудился, он просто фрустрирован, не дошел вообще никуда.
Также на каждую сессию выходит коэффициент трения
и какие-то ключевые проблемы, которые возникали.
Можем открыть и посмотреть опять же здесь все действия пользователя.
И последнее здесь это находки.
Какие-то важные штуки, которые стоит передать агенту,
чтобы дальше с ним раскрыть проблемы, развить их,
может быть сделать обновления по твоему флоу и так далее.
Можно открыть каждую из них отдельно.
Здесь выводится, что показал тест, как мы поймем, что починили эту проблему и куда вообще можно копать.
Нажимаем передать агенту.
Это все скопировалось в буфер.
Можем нажать сюда все находки, скопировать и весь этот текст со всеми находками сразу закинуть агенту.
Можно нажать скачать, чтобы этот файлик целиком скачать.
И еще одна важная штука это, во-первых, обновление.
Если у тебя какая-то там новая сессия сюда не подгрузилась,
можно нажать обновить, она обязательно появится.
И еще одна функция это зафиксировать раунд.
Что это делает?
Вот, например, ты собрал новый сценарий, отдал его на тест.
Пользователи прошли, собрались какие-то метрики, хорошие, плохие.
Собрались какие-то метрики и они тебя не устраивают.
Это неплохие, нужно дорабатывать сценарий, дорабатывать flow, возможно, уже по каким-то находкам, которые для тебя здесь собрались.
Ты нажимаешь зафиксировать раунд, проводишь еще раз этот самый тест и смотришь, как сильно с предыдущим раундом изменились твои метрики.
Выглядеть это будет примерно так.
Но сейчас я новые раунды тестирования не проводил.
Тут добавляется такой блок, в котором видно спад либо повышение тех или иных метрик.
Вот, например, я открыл ссылку, еще немного потыкал, добавилась новая сессия, даже две.
И здесь он уже выводит метрики, что доход до цели у нас стал меньше.
Было 100%, стало 50%.
Крупнейший отвал 50% и так далее.
Сюда ты можешь выводить какие угодно тебе метрики.
Достаточно попросить агента как угодно.
Дашборд ты можешь крутить и дорабатывать под свой продукт, под свой подход.
Он у многих отличается.
На этом все. Ссылку на NGROG, архив с дашбордом, директиву ты найдешь, как обычно, в описании под этим уроком.
В качестве домашнего задания тебе нужно будет сделать то же самое.
Прогнать пару U-тестов, просто, ну там, не знаю, руками потыкать, посмотреть, что у тебя собираются метрики,
что у тебя проходят сессии.
Сделать скрин и отправить в Zen Class.
Также можешь прикрепить какую-нибудь интересную находку, которую у тебя дашборд нашел.
Также можешь прикрепить какую-нибудь интересную находку, которую нашел твой вот этот микросервис.
На этом все.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания и увидимся в следующем видео.